cannibalism asexuality and violence a
society that had collapsed what's going
on here
[Music]
in 1972 John B Calhoun detailed the
specifications of a Utopia designed for
mice built in the laboratory
every aspect of universe 25 as this
particular model was called was designed
to cater for the well-being of its
rodent residence increased their
lifespan and allow them to mate
there was abundant food water and
nesting material the universe was
cleaned regularly there were no
Predators the temperature stable
Paradise or maybe not
four pairs of disease-free mice selected
from the National Institute of Health's
Elite breeding Colony moved in on day
one
it took months for the rodents to
familiarize themselves with their new
world then they started to reproduce and
the population increased exponentially
doubling every 55 days those were the
good times in Paradise
past day 315 more than 600 mice now
lived in Universe 25 rubbing shoulders
on their way up and down the stairwells
to eat drink and sleep population growth
slowed
young ones found themselves born into a
world with far more mice than meaningful
social roles males faced a lot of
competitors to defend their territory
against many found that so stressful
they gave up normal discourse within the
community broke down and with it the
ability of mice to form social bonds
lone females retreated to isolated
nesting boxes on Penthouse levels
other males a group Calhoun termed the
beautiful ones never sought sex and
never fought they just ate slapped and
groomed wrapped in narcissistic
introspection
elsewhere cannibalism asexuality and
violence became endemic Mouse Society
had collapsed
on day 560 the population peaked at 2200
mice a few mice survived past weaning
until day 600 after which there were few
pregnancies and no surviving young as
the population had stopped regenerating
itself its path to Extinction was clear
the mice had lost the capacity to
rebuild their numbers many that could
still conceive such as the beautiful
ones and their secluded Singleton female
counterparts had lost the social ability
to do so
on day 920 was the last conception the
last Mouse died on May 23
1973. four years and 10 months after
colonization
Calhoun later said that the creatures
had died two deaths the first was that
of their spirit and their society the
second death was that of their physical
body
it was not the first time the ethologist
had built a world for rodents Calhoun
had been creating utopian environments
for rats and mice since the 1940s with
consistent results
overpopulation leads to explosive
violence and hypersexual activity
followed by asexuality self-destruction
and Extinction
in his widely cited paper population
density and social pathology Calhoun
concluded no matter how sophisticated we
are once the number of individuals
capable of filling social roles greatly
exceeds the number of such roles only
violence and disruption can follow he
then referred to a phenomenon he called
behavioral sync
behavioral sync is our desire to be in
the presence of others to be conditioned
to seek to be near others and to be
drawn to the crowd in spite of the
conflicts that this can generate
drawing from Calhoun's popular research
social scientists started to call for
restrictions on reproduction as the only
possible response to the world's Rising
population Calhoun himself was more
optimistic about our future he argued as
our physical space declines we are
forced to extend a conceptual space our
network of ideas and Technologies
later in his career he turned to
possible solutions and began to build
creative universes that minimize the ill
effects of overcrowding
what are your thoughts is overcrowding a
danger for mankind or does it only
affect rodents and if so what can save
the human psyche avoiding eye contact in
crowded places is one strategy but is
that enough to read more about Universe
25 and its cultural impact read the
paper of Edmund ramsden and John Adams
you'll find a link in the description
below
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities